when call of duty advanced warfare comes
to mind so should the exosuit no longer
do you have to rely on weapons and perks
to get through the night
switch on your XO and light the room up
combating foes with a dash combo or
powering up those EXO abilities will
help you reign supreme on the field
it's your EXO suit baby here's how to
use it to the left to the left to the
right to the right
your first standard EXO move is the -
and it's hands-down your new bestie
case in point oncoming fire tears you
apart and you're close to death it's
time to bust a move power - out of the
fire so you can fight another day how
about those one-on-one showdowns let's
dance
throw in a juke and psych them out once
you've mastered the horizontal playing
field strap in because we're getting
vertical the boost jump changes advanced
warfare once again double jump and
leashes the power for anyone to take the
higher ground channel the spirit of the
feline call I'm to the highest peak of
the map and pounce on your unsuspecting
prey rial up-down left-right is that it
not if you're thinking about them
separately here's where the true
ballerinas make the cut combo your
double jump with a dash and dance your
way for the gold medal only with an
added jump can you now forward - giving
you the ability to quickly leap
distances or even better freak someone
out like a deer in the headlights and
you'll definitely want to throw in a
forward dash to speed a flag captures
and uplink dunks where combos really
take form are in the jump left or right
- combos once again you can cheat death
jumping out of a hot zone and then dash
behind cover or how about a game-changer
surprised spot above you walking along
the catwalk above you jump up and left
BAM he did not see that coming anyone
can pull a sweet - combo but with EXO
abilities it's your time to shine choose
one of seven EXO abilities that cater to
your play style be wary though because
your EXO battery offers a finite amount
of power per life so use it sparingly
first up the EXO shield say you're
pinned on top of a roof with minimal
cover - - for without that shield and
prolong the hail of gunfire giving you
time to prepare for your next plan of
action
unsatisfied with your exosuits prints XO
overclock should hit the spot tap that
left bumper and race like the wind
perfect for outrunning foes and CTF or
if we're combating the weight and
bulkiness of the xmg providing the
necessary speed for gaining ground and
locking down on those precious beachhead
positions
let it rain or maybe you're getting
tired of dying so often especially since
there are no longer death streaks from
earlier Cod's well time to Opie that
health with the XO stim charged up with
this XO special to generate health
quicker than the average Joe pump up
like a meathead and outlast all those
wussies in the ring fire up XO stem and
uplink offering vital time in those
last-second dunks flip your play style
around a bit get off those steroids and
get stealthy put on the XO cloak and
sneak your way through enemy territory
for the flag in CTF or get the upper
hand on the drone and uplink taste the
rainbow XO and they won't see it coming
fan of the XO - and the Jukes add the XO
hover to your arsenal you're being
chased into a room hug the corner jump
throw on your hover and watch them
stroll under you like a bunch of idiots
but hey don't plow into a room take a
breath and sink become a tactician with
XO ping
hit the switch and scan the area using
pain will only spot other players using
the XO movement or firing weapons yeah
considering that's what everyone's doing
anyway you'll do just fine radar man and
lastly you got the XO trophy power on
this EXO ability and destroy any
grenades or rock it's headed towards
your face and since we're talking a
total of about 10 different projectiles
to end your life the XO trophy is
definitely worth considering all these
EXO abilities are yours for choosing oh
and remember when I said you can only
choose one I lied tossing down the
tactician wildcard means double EXO
abilities for some double trouble you
lose your nades in the process but on
the + XO ability combinations can make
for some sweet sweet classes the EXO
baby it's a game changer